[Applause]
so you're not on board with
uh like getting trump off twitter and
all these things no
talk to me i think it's
so people say that he incited this but
he never really said like yo
go to the capitol and kill people
he never said go to the cabin and kill
people he said yo let's show em
there's enough circumstantial evidence i
think and this is where you said he's
like a mob boss he never says he knows
the phones or tape that's what i'm
saying never says the specific thing you
can take him to a court of law over
but twitter ain't got a law they're
literally storming the capital he goes
all right guys yo we gotta be peaceful
go home i love you you're special
like what is i love you you're special
at i'm saying he's one with words he
knows
how to not incriminate himself so it's
like if he's not technically breaking
the rule i don't think he should be
punished
right now i will say it goes against
what happened there what i feel it was
[ __ ] up what happened there but still
it's like
this guy he's still abiding by the rules
of these sites
now the other piece is that they say
okay we're gonna have another rally on
the daily inauguration so
he's like we're going to run it back 2.0
day the inauguration let's let's do it
yeah but then he goes just so everyone
knows i'm not going to be there
so if anyone wants to do anything i'm
not there
do whatever you got to do now that's
different he said i'm not gonna be the
inauguration he said he's not gonna be
there but now he didn't say if anybody
wants to do it so this is the question
is like twitter is looking into the
subtext of what he's saying they're
saying are his followers gonna see this
and do
2.0 what they did last time you know not
showing up to the inauguration
is so [ __ ] my name is so [ __ ]
i honestly what was endearing about
trump is that he wasn't [ __ ]
is that he was calling all these
[ __ ] out on their [ __ ] and
to see him
be such a sour puss loser
yeah yeah sort yo nothing is worse than
a sore loser yeah
being a sour puss sore loser yeah son
how how can you lose all respect in an
instance
i'm not showing up i'm not going to be
there like loki is whack that they gotta
go like if you lost
but it is what it is that's part of it
fam you got to be the most powerful
person in the world for four years
[ __ ] inauguration it's a sign that we
believe in peaceful transfer of power
that's what it is that's what democracy
is well yeah i lost
all right keep it moving yes hand it off
and we need that handoff that handoff is
very important it lets everybody know
hey this is how it's supposed to go it's
healthy we shouldn't have these [ __ ]
battles every time there's a presidency
the uh the presidency goes in a way that
maybe half of the country didn't want
because every [ __ ] election is half
the country's pissed
yeah and you were out here being a
little crying [ __ ] about it yeah
i'm not showing up yep such a [ __ ]
lame thing dude
yeah the censorship is so weird man it's
it's just a weird thing because you're
almost just like you can't let people
incite revolutions well
you can because sometimes you need a
revolution
it's real tricky bro yeah well i mean i
don't get the legal thing where people
are saying that it's a violation of the
first amendment
yeah people keep saying that but free
speech is not absolute like you can't
say i'm gonna kill the president that's
that's something you get prosecuted for
yeah you know what i mean
there are certain things that are you're
saying there are certain things that are
carved out of free speech no country has
absolute free speech you can't yell fire
in a crowded building that's something
you can't punish for yeah
shouldn't even talk in a crowded theater
especially theater
in history
you're like implantation houses look
comfy oh how do we [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
oh he says i want a ranch oh no
i said ranch ranch is not racist
ranchero
do you think mexicans are raising you
know who loves ranch racist white folks
that's true women with wings black
people don't [ __ ] with ranch
nah nah blue cheese yeah come on i
actually had a friend that says me
that said that black people don't like
any white food he said well he said him
personally he said i don't like any
white foods
what does that mean you said one black
person said black people and you're like
well he said he personally
yeah well that's what he said it went
down to the one black guy he knows
and you're also his puerto rican friend
yeah you honestly check off a lot of
boxes
that's a triple word score right there
bro
yeah scrabble media over here that's
true
[Music]
okay bro so look jacket lets me know
he's lgbtq yeah
that's a good ass point got the whole
rainbow in there and b
bro okay so yeah i don't know why it's a
violation of the first amendment the
first amendment says you you can't pass
laws that prohibit freedom of speech
religion all that [ __ ]
this is like twitter is not the law no
one's passing a law that says if you say
something you go to jail
like in china you criticize like wait
which one is first amendment
that's freedom of speech okay so
but if you he can't speak freely on
these platforms and therefore
he is violation of freedom of the first
amendment would be like what they have
in china you talk [ __ ] about
taiwan you go to jail well that's what
this is right he's talking [ __ ] about
america
but he's not going he's not going to
jail ah
so only prison if there's a law that
says you say this
[ __ ] you get prison time fines sanctions
other types of legal
punitive punishment yeah or punitive
action
is the only thing that makes it a
violation of the first amendment that's
what he said
saying you're not welcome on our private
company in twitter i don't okay so fully
trust their intention
and i think there's gonna be a lot of
overviews [ __ ] up but you can't use
first amendment for twitter banning him
like
you coming to my house say wild [ __ ] i
can kick you out now we're on uh
now we're on a different okay so like
some restaurants for example say
um uh none of the ones you would ever go
to
no they're like dress codes right how
happy are you that those restaurants are
gonna shut down because
i'm so happy to text me every weekend oh
you know a good restaurant
i only support mom abdominals that's how
i say
that
mcdonald's yo you got to check out
jiggety dende that's one of my favorite
places
so we have um a situation here where
big tech and i even i hate the term big
tech it seems it's just like somebody
everybody throws out but like
these platforms have become so big that
they're almost like a part of
human life right or american or like
western whatever you want to call they
become like countries yes
they're countries in the way that they
operate in the amount of people that are
with them and also the rules that
they're dictating
but at the same time like it almost
feels like you're right as an american
citizen to
uh operate on these platforms yeah right
so at what point does
a tech platform become part of a
civil right at what point is it so big
that it becomes part of your civil
rights i don't think whatever i don't
you don't think ever
because their excuse is this we're
approaching it i think i i think we're
approaching
i'll say something interesting that
happened to uh uh my uh
my girl's stepdad he was on vacation and
uh
he was a on like a snorkeling thing or
whatever like that and
there's always you know interesting
people when you're on these things he's
just talking he spoke to a google fact
checker
and she was a google fact checker and he
was just like so how do you like get
that job and do you think it's weird
that you get to be like the arbiter of
truth like you get to decide what
things are true and what things aren't
true that's got a lot of responsibility
and she said to him
well if you don't like that you don't
have to use google
there really isn't any other google yeah
there's another one called
duck some [ __ ] there's something duck
duck go
you ain't using yahoo you're not using
this yahoo king
all those whatever things you didn't
even get the name right it's big that's
how much you ain't using that's racial
bro that's
on you now yeah that's true so it's like
you can yeah
but you it's not right let's be honest
like if you're not on google
if your business isn't googleable if all
these things like nobody's using
duckduckgo
to find the restaurant or to find
flagrant 2 or to find any of these
things
right there's one there's one place
right so
it's not like you have but they get to
hide behind that
they get to hide behind that like
technicality that technicality if you
will that like yeah we're just a regular
business and
yeah we'll buy up all of our
competitions so there isn't any but
we're just a regular business it is what
it is
so what happened what i thought was
really interesting he asked what she
used to do beforehand
right do you know what she used to do
before she was a fact checker
she worked for the [ __ ] state
department and i'm like
oh [ __ ] is this why big tech hasn't been
broken up
why break up the thing that can do your
work for you the best possible way
right from the state department into big
tech where you decide the truth
narratives that you want to
put out there in the world so now you
have
the deep state or whatever i want to
talk about in a conspiratorial way i
want to talk about like a realistic way
beforehand there was obviously some sort
of relationship between
government and news media right
journalism
and government were somewhat intertwined
and then it became
right-wing media and left-wing media
were intertwined through different
government organizations but there was
obviously a relationship
there was like narratives being pushed
out between them now it seems to me
that you have that same government
relationship intertwined
with big tech which is real news now
that's where we're getting all
our information and you place the people
who decide what is true or what's not
true
in those positions of power and of
course you don't break them up you're
like thank god we're working together
boys
yeah girl brought up that exact thing
she was like i don't like this because
there's no way this isn't done
out of their own self-interest no way
they don't give a [ __ ] about the general
well-being of the country
well no let me ask you a question i do
it now here's the one thing
we assume nefarious intent whenever
there's control or censorship
okay i think that's pretty natural
that's a great sentence but we do right
yeah that was far
right so but the reality is maybe it's
not always
nefarious maybe there's some people who
are like listen for us to get where we
need to go
in the next 50 years the next 100 years
obviously there are people that are
plotting the course of america
way beyond where we when we will ever be
here there's a reason we made louisiana
purchase there's a reason for manifest
destiny there's a reason we go from
pacific to uh sorry from atlantic to
pacific there are people that are going
hey we need to be here for 500 more
years what do we need to do now in order
to be there
and there are people that exist in those
roles right now and maybe some of them
are are looking at this landscape and
then making those decisions based on
that
and saying these are the important
truths to get us where we need to go
yeah okay and so far
i know this sounds like a kind of a
bitch-ass approach to it maybe it's a
optimistic approach but so far
they've done okay with america so
they're looking out for their own
well-being but also
we're looking out for american
well-being and then we'll get everything
we can yeah because their well-being is
contingent on the health of the nation
what is the one thing right there what
is the one thing let's say the powers
that be or the rich people
what is the one thing that terrifies
rich people
i mean there's many but what is one big
one
revolution of the poor insurrection yeah
everything else they can handle
right stock market flows they don't care
they're billionaires
i'll try and stock market exactly and if
it does go down we'll just buy up some
depressed real estate or whatever the
[ __ ] is out there we can take advantage
of
but insurrection terrifies the rich
yeah because a what is it called a a
well-structured and polite
and just society allows them to keep
their money in a safe place
they don't want to exist where they got
50 [ __ ] armed guards around their
palatial estate
like they have to and i'm sure india
they have to in parts of mexico and
parts of south america
they're literally prisoners within their
wealth yeah every revolution they
[ __ ] eat the rich
bring out the guillotine chop off
marriage when that's head chop chop chop
yeah
so i think this was terrifying to them
and i think this kicks [ __ ] into high
gear they're like
yo yo yo yo we need to do something
cause
we are next we're the rich and we could
get eaten
so i think that's why you saw those
drastic measures people all of a sudden
being chopped off of on twitter i think
the conversation goes to jack
dorsey or whatever the twitter guy is
and
my buddy said this and i thought this
was kind of interesting he was like
he is not a big government guy he is
like a super libertarian he thinks
politicians are [ __ ] idiots but he
goes
right now the conversation comes to who
do i trust
with the truth more donald trump or jack
dorsey at twitter
he goes i actually trust jack yeah
kind of interesting yeah i think also
what makes it tricky is that they banned
trump's personal twitter account
yeah they didn't ban the white house
they didn't ban at potus
so they banned trump as a private
individual that was using twitter with
the influence of the president united
states
so like they banned like how they banned
regular people for
violating the rules of twitter so
there's still a platform and a portal
for the president to communicate with
his constituency with the people of the
united states either through
those actual social portals but also
just how the way presidents used to
communicate which is
through press conference yeah press
briefing and things like that
so i don't see that there's any sort of
like legal
issue with banning trump from twitter i
do think though that
twitter has inserted itself into a
political like political like
geopolitical conversation that i don't
know if they're ready to handle
so like they now have broken
because like the rule for like all of
time before this was that like if
there's a state head
where he's gonna operate under a
different set of rules than other people
on twitter so we have specific rules and
if like the president of iran
or like ayatollah or whatever is like
saying crazy [ __ ] that violates our
rules
we're going to leave them up because
it's important for the citizens of the
world and also their citizens to be able
to read it that's right a lot of people
are pointing to
pointing to uh khamenei not being taken
down right and it's like why the [ __ ] is
this guy in iran who has said you know
i'm sorry death to israel
yeah wipe israel off the planet exactly
it's like he said all these hateful
things that
seem to potentially incite violence as
well why hasn't he been removed
when we have the president of the united
states being removed
very interesting